Give yourself a reality check when you go to the dealer to buy a new car.
If you have nine kids and a Saint Bernard, and it's gonna be your daily driver,...
...don't go look at the cute little Mini, sorry.
This is how you need to think:...
...who's in your car most of the time?
Do you have kids?
So you made bad life choices.
Do they need car seats, do they need a booster seat?
Or are they teenagers?
Or maybe you have older parents...
...or people with special needs or handicaps to think about.
Second consideration is fuel economy.
Do you really care...
...if you drive a lot of miles? You probably do.
Last consideration, how do you use your car?
Are you in a car pool rotation or can you live with just two doors?
Do you need cargo space?
Are you in stop-and-go traffic or do you live in the Great White North?
Do you need four-wheel drive...
...or will front drive work just as well as that gas-sucking four-wheeler?